[Music]
you had a great honor you got to throw
the first pitch out at a White Sox game
and this is something that means a lot
oh you kid I mean listen I grew up south
side of Chicago I grew up with two
dreams one to host a talk show two to
play baseball for the White Sox and I'm
honored that I get to work on this
program I get to come out here every day
and be on this stage and that's a great
honor for me so there I was we went and
did a week of shows in Chicago yes our
whole show went there and and everybody
got to have a good time and you and the
night before we started the day before
we started the Chicago White Sox excited
invitation for me to throw out the first
pitch right so there I was representing
this show which I'm very proud to work
on and throw out the pitch for the team
that I've you know watch every single
game since 1977 I they they make the
offer I get tuned up I mean you felt
them there a second ago
it's it's a I went to the field I'm
throwing the ball out I'm getting loose
I'm you know I'm stretching out I
brought my glove I got my Jersey in the
head I'm all set to go
I throw the first pitch boom everybody
the place goes bananas did you got it
over the plane I got it over yes I got
it over the place a lot of people don't
put you at you you you did damn right I
did
don't get all attitude E on me very
insulting when you say I don't think I
am I think I was asking a fair question
as journalists first of all very strong
word for you okay
no reason now listen to me what's up you
listen up I'm in charge here that's what
the desk means and that's what the mic
means you don't touch it I touch it I
cannot touch this at all can't touch it
could I look at it no you have to look
up here into the golden zone all the
highs now my question for you is you
threw the ball and you it was a strike
it was it elicited very kind it was just
it depending if it would be batting was
either a little inside or a little
outside but the the catcher did not have
to did not have to reach at all he just
kind of get a little bit like that so a
great proud moment for you and the place
went crazy ladies goes crazy and I doff
my cap the place goes bananas it's up on
the big screen I'm there with my son and
my father it was a great you know a
generational thing never seen my dad
prouder than this moment and I go to
sleep on my top of the world can't wait
to come to work the next day we're gonna
be at the Chicago theater beautiful
venue and I wake up to about 75 text
messages telling me you got a look at
the Chicago sun-times you're on the back
page the entire back page is you the
Chicago sun-times I'm on top of the
world I run downstairs from the hotel
room I go to the Starbucks I buy the
stack of them but I flip open to flip
over to the back page and there it is
there's a picture of me throwing out the
first pitch and I'm pretty sure we do we
have a shot of that we have it and you
weren't pleased with this
[Applause]
it's perfect
he just threw a bunch of violets
fantastic top of the world - oh now I
got to buy every paper in Chicago yeah